[Musique]
et vous plaît les cherry on va jouer au
cache-cache contrat c'est très simple
vous allez partir à deux à chaque fois
on a caché vos contrats dans le hall
d'accord les chérit le premier qui me
ramène son contrat bibi ce sera validée
validé va valider elle est validée est
d'ailleurs bazarder on leur a tout à
l'heure en live à venir le grand public
sera avec nous il y aura l'artiste
également il y aura sliman il y aura ce
limal padam padam on arrive à moi ma
gueule et mon sac à dos sur pied mais
pas vous fermez une infâme et vogel est
libre je faisais guérir justement c'est
pour vous allécher riez vous allez
partir deux par deux on va déjà essayer
de valider le premier contrat entre
valérie et maxime
attention vous allez partir tous les
deux le premier qui me ramène son
contrat je le valais l'itie après c'est
mort s'est déchiré ça déchire attention
les attentions
retour la version opc 3 je voudrais
cette fois sur les gens s'attaquent
partout mais adam centrage crois qu'il
est dans son genre au pack ouais tiens
tiens au nom non autorisée
d'établissement [ __ ] la loma mondiale
alors ici santé quoi y'a quoi dedans
l'effet de l'aider à les laver la
lecture grâce à l'événement là bas alors
mais le blé mais à très drôle et benali
la trouver c'est pas toi elle regarde
les vérifier blacks c'est votre contrat
[Musique]
social
c'est lui qui a gagné
[Applaudissements]
les allocutions ton contrat rien non
mais c'est passé mais n'a rien
santé centre avait là les banques
hellènes à ivato chaud et c'est vrai ils
sont pénalisés
voilà
[Musique]
j'ai validé ces deux contre un on
n'arrive même pas voilà bravo à l'égard
de ces données attention vous est donné
mais malheureusement pour l'instant
contre benhaim regarder la société
c'est con ils ont fait l'erreur de ne
faudrait pas possible si je suis pas
dans les prairies bravo à batz-sur-mer
si vous l'aviez chiffres les chercheurs
se calment deuxième deuxième contrat
valide et hyzaar contre daniel on
attendait à béziers ou l'a61 comprend
daniel très attention je ne parle ni
placé mais laissez vos chaussures ici
c'est finalement il peut me servir
attendez on préfère le faire pour donner
il m'a chanté allez on y va
3 a laissé les choses aller vite en tout
cas elles vont vite allé leur dire que
j'allais me david koubbi dans une sphère
du nazisme et la première qui trouve son
contrat est ce que ça va être
isabelle sauter des avions cherché
partout partout
[Applaudissements]
alors quand même être sur une personne
ah ouais mais mature une personne n'est
allé la roulotte attention ou bien bien
bien il est oui ou non plus rien à sucre
en voiture une personne ça peut être
également dans une plante dans une
plante c'est peut-être parce qu'il ya
sûrement mieux regarder ce que c'est le
sien daniel malavergne dias est en cours
de son voyage il était devant vite
l'adroit la mer j'attends d'abord oui
[Applaudissements]
isabelle morini bosc
c'est bon on la retrouvera dans deux ans
attention là là là ça va être chaud
enora et agathe et après on aura en face
l état à jean michel adam en année moi
je le fais à ma sortie j'ai pas là mais
ce n'est pas fini ne vous battez pas
enlever mon âme et ne lève pas leurs
talons elle reste sexy en toute
circonstance pas beau et très beau vase
inondées dès la fin du match j'étais
bien
ces mines par la motion et elle vous
tout ça par la main les bouffonne à
l'essai il voit enora ya quatre mois la
gagne et mal à gagner n'est versée pour
les seuls cadres à ce qu'ils doivent
aller au stade et pas loin la meilleure
est meilleur que motta trice de course
c'est bon j'ai remarqué médaillés de la
meuf elle est là elle est arrivée elle
jane white est pas loin
you bet à gâteaux pour agathe au crew
malaga et nova malheureusement michel y
aura d'autres occasions te plait pas je
peux pas attention attention attention
gilles verdez et jean michel maire
attention les blessés vont y laisser
faire mal forcément mais bon je sais
qu'on pouvait être celle où la whey
l'avocat continue à bosser là tous les
mecs moi j'attends ce jour qu'un début
mai son contrat le plus de gens me et
chine prête à aller j'en dis oui
il atteint boussara départ du meilleur
acteur
daniel
[Applaudissements]
gilles verdez j'ai mal contre
gilles verdez racontera et est validé
bravo malheureusement j jean-michel
heures on n'a plus de nouvelles
et c'est pareil
c'étaient les chérissait
ça fait très plaisir bonjour je devais
en mots je vous le dis on vous en
parlera dans un instant moi je compte
l'appeler matthieu delormeau a eu un
petit souci va nous dire tout ça donc il
va arriver là dans quelques instants
nous faire benjamin castaldi
oui c'est validé segal et hazara quatre
avions chéri d'amour
jmb recevez mes chéris roma trop
l'engin instant ne monte pas le plateau
et sous ça va être la folie d'un groupe
on va parler médian qu'on a plein de
trucs à dire parce que ça se passe sur
ces 8 tout le monde est apparemment bien
sûr c'est vite donc on vous dira la
vérité et qui vient et qui ne vient pas
à tuer et ma chérie à tous de tripoter